[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey everyone i'm brian wood technical
communications and outreach manager at
wolfram
i'm here with shadi ashnai manager of
sound and vision
uh welcome shoddy how are you doing
today thanks brian doing fine
uh shoddy's gonna show me some of the
latest
video and image processing functionality
in the wolfram language
so give me kind of an overview here
what's uh what's the general direction
of
image and video processing in the
wolfram language right now
our major focus since last year has been
video of course it's the newest feature
we released in version 12.1
all experimental as a lot of it is
evolving as we speak
so most of the team has been focused
from the import
export side of it to basic editing and
being able to show
some gui that works in the notebook as
well as advanced analysis which is
we all believe is gonna be the strength
of having any video support in our
wolfram language so that has been taking
a lot of effort a lot of resources from
the team
but um we've as well continued working
on our image and audio capabilities
whether it's better support for file
formats
looking at looking back at existing
functions
making adjustments or improvements
implementing suggestions
or even adding any utility functions or
or even bigger features like face
analysis stuff that is
really important and nice for us to have
yeah well and and i know image and
signal processing
and audio processing and video
processing it's all sort of uh linked
together and it's been a pretty big area
in general
i think in industry so it's pretty great
for us to be implementing all that stuff
over the past few years so and you
actually gave a talk about this
last year as well um so why don't we
just start with some of the stuff that's
sort of new since last year
sure um do you want me to share
uh yeah yeah maybe show some examples as
well
um so i think since last year
when we spoke um i believe video was not
released but we were
working on releasing um video
just just to recall video is a
is a first-class citizen an object in
the system it displays
as a video gui a video player
we have our default as a thumbnail
viewer which is a small
thumbnail of one of the frames of the
video opens up in an external
video player but we do have other gui's
which are basically our working
prototype for
having an in notebook player um
this is a snippet of um
this is this is basically the future
that we are trying to work
to have uh right so it's just
built in right there in the notebook
navigate through it turn the volume up
and down things like that right
right and this video has one track only
but we do support multi-track
video multi-track uh multi multiple
audio tracks subtitle tracks and so
forth and
and this gui already is capable of
either displaying or
emitting the sound from different audio
tracks or showing subtitles
uh for different tracks so so when you
say it supports
several tracks those are sort of
something that's built into
whatever video you're importing that the
system then recognizes okay
cool exactly for instance if i get
another example here
um
and i really like our video examples
here too they're a lot of fun
right and for instance this video has
three audio tracks two um subtitle
tracks
and with the gui um let me get an older
version
um just just a gui in the prototype
build i'm using
uh has a glitch on those but if i can
get
my 12 1 running i can show you how the
we can switch between those
but the support doesn't end at the gui
display
it actually also
all right let me see if i can get one
notebook here
okay
so here it is all our multi-track
video object i can start
playing i can switch to show
any of the site subtitles or even play
any of the male adult has red under
parts
but females and young birds have gray
under parts
i see okay and and the support does not
um
stop at just displaying or emitting the
sound from different audio tracks
even in processing and analysis um
all of those tracks are coming together
you can
um you know do analysis based on the
birth sound from first audio track or do
speech recognition on the second audio
track and so forth
wow yeah so every everything is just
ready to be analyzed
very cool
um okay so um just to continue on that
uh on what got released into a one um
let me reevaluate this one
uh quickly so uh the kaminanda's example
that we had was a one video track one
audio track
um it's an mp4 and and the codec
is one of the most typical codecs h.264
aac
the support for very many formats and
codecs
has been one of the major efforts we put
into
our video project before top one and
there has been very little work on that
after 201 it is solid it it supports as
you see
for let's say mp4 almost all
codecs that are out there for mp4 and
also other
containers that we support this is
our video decoders which means which
formats we can consume
and same thing for video encoders
which basically tells us what formats
we're using what containers we can
create
video files so that's
a sense of it 12.1 basically has video
as first class citizen
and we are complete as as far as what
types of videos we support
all right so what else do we have that's
sort of uh up and coming
in the new uh 12.2 then um okay so very
briefly since i just have them up there
um small things that got added into a
one as well just to make sure we
it's not just the bare bones things like
trimming
um you know a portion of a video
extracting some frames
from a video and then you can
immediately feed them to
functions that are supported or coming
from our image processing suite like
image collage
or extracting the whole audio track from
a video object and then performing audio
was
also a major piece so accessing
different parts of video was available
we have had some general processing and
analysis
i guess my favorite is video time series
of some measurement in in this case i'm
doing mean intensity frame by frame
looking at video frames computing some
property doesn't have to be meaning mean
intensity
um something that
we are proud of is you know this these
progress indicators that for video is
kind of essential
we developed on that and the whole
system is going to use this progress
indication framework
and then again the whole system just
comes together when you want to
visualize or analyze further the data
that was computed
programmatic playback was also important
and essential
specifically when in the future we do
get to
real-time analysis of video files
a very simple example i can create a
stream connected to a video file and
then
if you recall we used to have dynamic of
edge detect of care and image as one of
our very basic examples
and now i have dynamic of edge detect of
current frame
from that video and if i start playing
you can do
quite a better processing on that yeah
so it's live processing the same way
that
a lot of our sort of camera image
processing
functions have been in the past already
exactly exactly
so this is what got released in 201
um you asked me what's coming next
one of the major things we spend some
time on and there is going to be more
time spent on it post 12 to his
generation
a lot of people want to generate videos
from their work
whatever it is in this example i have a
geometry of a horse
and most of the times you interactively
go around to see
the 3d object if you want to show this
to somebody
just revolve through the 3d object we we
are introducing
something called video generator and
this goes through and basically what i'm
doing i'm performing some geometric
transformation which is a
rotation transform around the horse um
i had this pre-comp computed so that we
don't have to wait for it 30 seconds
but um anyways this is this is not
taking a lot of time anyways i'm
creating a lot of
um frames um and once this is done
the video is generated immediately we
wrap the video object it it gets
represented in the notebook as video
object and one can perform any analysis
on it or just share it with anyone
as the file is there and it can be sent
to anyone
i see so it's uh maybe kind of similar
to like
like an animate or a list animate except
it's more
video and not just uh not just a
series of images it is it is gonna be
this is
this is this is the feature of our
prototype build uh
nightly builds but um this is a file
this is an out of core file it can
potentially be hours of generated video
um as opposed to animated um
list animate which is all in core you
need to have all of the data for all of
the frame
in the notebook which obviously gets
infeasible if you have
a very long um series of images right
yeah yeah that out of core is uh key for
for any large video projects for sure of
course of course
and that makes it possible for us to be
able to consume or generate
any kind of video at this point without
that
out of core support we were limited to a
few seconds of low resolution
uh video files right so does that
does that also help i mean does that
speed up the process
does that change how how quickly you can
create videos and
the analysis or not necessarily because
you have to write every if
if my video fit in my memory it would be
obviously
faster um to create everything in memory
uh just like list animate and play with
it that way the
import and export the io process is
going to be unnecessary if everything is
in core
but once you have out of core what it
enables is the fact that
um you can have large amount of data
sitting on the memory and then you fetch
as much as you need
however we we have put a lot of effort
into making sure our
our i o process is as fast as possible
and we are still looking at it and
trying to make it more efficient
whenever we find
room for improvement gotcha yeah that
makes sense so there's always
a little bit of a trade-off but it's
still optimized to the best of
our language's ability cool of course of
course
along the lines of generation we also
extend video stream
into all two in order to be able to
capture stream
capture video from screens so your
monitors
or the webcam again this is similar
to dynamic of current image
in instead of creating you dynamic
images and discarding them
if you're capturing frames from the
webcam we're capturing them and putting
them in a file
um i i won't demo this but this is the
kind of syntax that is going to happen
just like
i was able to do dynam you know dynamic
of current frame of the video that i was
playing
um i can basically dynamics dynamically
see the frame that is coming from the
screen or the webcam
and then record it into a file and then
at the end
one of the very useful use cases of this
for instance in
built into our system is if somebody is
say
presenting from a mathematical notebook
and then instance
instantly they can record their notebook
and record themselves and
basically have those uh recordings those
videos available
on their site cool yeah that seems like
it would be really useful just for
sort of live streams and things like
that where people are showing off their
code and
yeah i know we we're big into the live
coding thing at wolfram so
very cool yeah um
what else um some editing capabilities
the list is long
we really don't think this is going to
be the essence and the value of wolfram
language when it comes to video
computations overall
but people need this day-to-day trim a
part of the video
transcode from this format this codec to
another um
combine the video track with audio track
sequentially join
or split or delete some unwanted parts
or reverse for some effects and so forth
so
this is a subset of lists of editing
capabilities that we would like to
eventually have implemented this is the
list that
most probably is going to come into 12 2
plus minus some functions i would say
and and the way we refer to this this is
this is
essential capability so that people can
do other more advanced analysis and
computation in our system
we don't necessarily think people are
going to come to us
to join two videos to connect to videos
there are way too many software out
there that can do that
but analyzing how many people came and
went from
you know in total in my video is
something that not every software is
capable of doing
right yeah and it's it's convenient if
you had just have those basic things
built into
the language so that you can lead up to
the more advanced stuff i imagine
of course you don't want to leave the
system in order to be able to
say for instance combine your already
generated video with
some audio that is sitting there
to get something like that right so
these are essential to have but i don't
think
these are gonna be the major strengths
of our language anyways
we have looked at general processing and
analysis
video frame map from version 121 is
staying
video time series is becoming video map
time series for those who have
looked at 201 capabilities so this one
is able to get one video track
transform it given a function say color
negated or edge detect or image adjust
whatever
image processing operation frame by
frame or
multiple frames by multiple frames for
instance blend five
five frames ten frames at a time to get
some kind of a blend effect over time
um so and then audio track apply new
function in 12.2 is going to be
basically the same concept for audio
tracks
one audio track sounds very low we can
just normalize that
or amplify that one audio track has some
clicks
just remove those and so forth so these
two are
basically corrections or general
processing for one track at the time
these are three very general functions
very big so all three of those
and the output input outputs well input
always video
one outputs a video one outputs a list
one outputs a time series which is
those results that you got back in the
list with the time stamps
all three of those are very general in a
sense that
the function can take image from video
track
audio chunks from audio track and
subtitle chunks from subtitle tracks
and it can consume data from any number
of tracks that exist in the video
and the function arbitrarily processes
all of those
only in the first case we require that
the output is either an image that goes
into a
video track or it's an image audio
combination that goes into an image
audio track
for the other two it's really flexible
like the example i have here
with the bullfinch this is going to
basically get renamed to that video map
list
um oh right um i i just had
had these uh precomputed so i may wait
on these and and again these are all
getting faster as we speak um but i can
i can run that function with
a function called with a function like
dominant colors to get
compute dominant colors of every frame
so this is the result of first 10 frames
i can do a tally of all colors detected
in
all the frames do a word cloud to see
what colors were more dominant overall
in the whole video and so forth
um so anyways these these functions are
going to be very general
these are the kinds of applications that
they can enable um
in our system yeah yeah it's really cool
that you can sort of take
um not only the video and audio itself
but the underlying data and sort of
do things with with that uh and
especially the
sort of visuals that i've seen so far
and some of these
uh seems like they'd be really useful
yes
yes and the list of our specific
analysis functions in 12 2 currently
includes one
that that i categorize in that which is
video intervals
um it it it is basically uh
working with the result that comes back
from video
map list or video map time series and
then it looks at um
it basically works with a criteria that
says
um do does the analysis fit this
criteria for instance
in this case those min and max of every
frame
min and max of pixel values of every
frame
defer less than by less than 0.1
somehow trying to find constant frames
all white or black
which sometimes is a defect sometimes is
you know a
segmenter indication and so forth and
then
as a result you get a list of intervals
where that criteria holds
um so from the kaminandus video we see
that
there is a chunk of black frames at the
beginning something in the middle
something towards the end right so it's
like
it's like finding uh positions or or
doing a select kind of thing but on a
video and on particular properties
right right and in fact those intervals
are exactly these intervals down here
where we get
close to zero those are those are
that's the same function that roughly
the same function here i use mean
intensity here i'm
differing min and max but basically the
same same concept
so those are the five intervals that
come back down here
cool yeah yeah i like that you've got
those two together too because that
makes a lot of sense
and uh just just as an advisory to users
there
there
has been some renames the whole set of
functionality is marked experimental for
a reason
uh when we were designing our general
processing analysis functions we
realized these names
make more sense so we ended up doing
this one rename from video time series
to video map time series
um same for track selection uh we're
going from
video tracks etc to video track
selection etc
just would be fair to mention that and
highlight that it is all going to be
highlighted in our documentation
reflected there so that the users will
be able to hopefully easily adapt to the
new syntax
right on uh we are we are just about out
of time but why don't you why don't you
take me through some of the uh
image specific stuff just real quick uh
maybe the coolest thing that is coming
i think very useful is a construct
called animated image
we're not doing much as far as
processing and analysis these guys in
the system
but we are able to display them um
up there in the notebook a lot of people
have them it's gonna be great for
you know it's just just like animated
gifs on the web as
useful as they are in that context they
are going to be useful now for us in our
system
gotcha okay uh we have improved some uh
of our
face analysis capabilities most
important feature is going to be
face recognize you have a data set of
people labeled
you could have multiple examples for
each class
and then ask for who this person is and
the result could come back
like so image scopes
are um a lot of people are used to
seeing
video video scopes or vector scopes
those are the names that people know
these by there is typically a grid of
multiple plots
including image histograms for instance
where people would like to do
color grading or any other sort of color
adjustment image adjustments these
these become very handy so these are two
new additions
in the system basically show the
distribution of color
in different spaces and a lot of import
export as i say
the connectivity has always been
a major focus for us for instance
hake files or hay files are becoming
more and more popular and we've added
support for
importing the depth and uh once you have
the depth and an image you can actually
display them
as um you know display the image on
a surface that is elevated by the depth
and so forth or or just to other things
like refocusing and things that are
these days very very common using depth
cameras
so cool yep that's about it for
12.2 all right well those were some
really interesting examples
uh thanks a lot uh for anyone watching
at home if you haven't thought about
using wolfram technology for
image and video processing audio
processing it's a good time to get
started
as you see we've got plenty of
improvements over the past year
lots of new functionality and all sorts
of new stuff
coming up in the pipeline so uh thanks
again this has been a lot of fun
um i appreciate you joining me today
thank you for having me bry
thanks for joining us you can check out
other wolfram tech talks live coding
streams and more on the wolfram research
youtube channel
or see what else is new at wolfram.com
you